[Music]
straight ahead on law on crime daily a
no knock warrant leads to the death of a
22 year old minneapolis man how the
city's mayor is reacting making these
policies we have
a sacred
and extremely important duty to honor
the sanctity of life plus we have been
able to take what we believe is a serial
killer off the streets and
had we've not done this we're pretty
sure that he would have killed again
jury selection begins as accused serial
killer robert hayes stands trial for
murder and a juror turned witness why
the famed scott peterson juror will take
the stand in an evidentiary hearing but
first chilling testimony in the
preliminary hearing for the parents of
accused high school shooter ethan
crumbly what was your thought in media
my thought was that it was
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin a preliminary hearing was held
for the parents of the accused michigan
high school shooter while defense
attorneys motioned to delay the hearing
a judge ordered the proceedings continue
in the case of jennifer and james
crumbly
both are charged with four counts of
involuntary manslaughter following the
shooting spree at oxford high school
last november prosecutors say their son
15-year-old ethan crumbly opened fire in
the school killing four students and
injuring others prosecutors say parents
jennifer and james crumbly actually
gifted their son the weapon that was
used in the school shooting and ignored
the multiple warning signs from the
school including disturbing drawings
made by ethan and reports that he kept a
bird's head in a jar on tuesday defense
attorneys argued the hearing should be
delayed as the prosecution has been slow
to turn over the evidence the evidence
includes some 3 000 pages of materials
70 hours of video and 10 hours of
recorded interviews a judge denied that
motion
multiple witnesses testified on tuesday
describing the moments following the
shooting and what jennifer crumbly asked
of her supervisor
when you heard about the shooting
did
was it public who was responsible for it
it was not what was your thought in
media
my thought was that it was even and tell
me why you thought it was immediate your
immediate thought wasn't even
because i know that they own guns and i
know that they go out shooting and that
math test with everything written on it
made me think that
it was them after that then you received
the next test
yes yes i believe so and what does it
say
omg andy he's going to kill himself he
must be the shooter
and then the next cast i need a lawyer
with police
and then what else ethan did it and what
does the text say
i need my job please don't judge me for
what my son did
and what did you think about that
i was
surprised by that test right
i was surprised she was worried about
her job at the time i thought she'd be
more worried about what was going on
joining us today is legal analyst kirk
nermey and terry austin to discuss the
crumbly parents hearing kirk in the
hearing the prosecution had a number of
witnesses testify including a horse farm
owner that wrote with jennifer what do
you think she and these other witnesses
kind of brought to the table for this
hearing
well brian ultimately the theme of this
case for the state this hearing has been
that the crumblies combined were both
bad people bad parents who ignored the
warning signs with their children with
ethan specifically because they were
busy with extramarital affairs and the
horses and this witness we saw the horse
farm owner that was a friend of
jennifer's we see that she can kind of
tie in some of this talk of extramarital
affairs but she also put some
tangibility on things when it comes to
the horses how much money did they spend
caring for the horses how much time did
they spend of their time and resources
they could have been using to get help
for their son
that and along with of course when
things came down the idea of wanting to
sell the horse to get the money so they
could flee so it all just wraps in
perfectly for the state with their theme
that they're trying to present to the
court so they can take this case to
trial absolutely no terry last week the
prosecution filed a motion about the
defendant showing pda or public displays
of affection in court is there anything
the judge could even do about that
though
well it is a free country so it might be
hard for the judge to control anybody's
behavior i mean generally unless it's
harmful or disruptive but i think
there's an argument to be made here that
that sort of behavior can be at least
disruptive because the attorney
basically should be telling his client
listen you need to focus this is a
serious case we have four people who
died there are others who were injured
and the fact that you are you know
displaying these
affectionate you know actions in court
absolutely means you're not focusing on
this case you're not being serious
enough and you're not taking this
seriously and that can be used against
them so it's not a good idea for them to
continue yeah we'll see how either the
judge prosecutor or defense attorneys
address this and see if it continues on
as this case develops still ahead on law
and crime daily an accused serial killer
finally has his day in court but first
will convicted killer scott peterson get
a new trial it all lies in the testimony
of one juror set to testify at a coming
hearing
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
former juror is granted immunity to
testify as convicted wipe killer scott
peterson request a new trial based on
bias and germ misconduct it all stems
from the 2004 trial where peterson was
found guilty for the 2002 murder of wife
lacey and unborn son connor peterson's
team says he did not receive a fair
trial alleging juror rochelle niece lied
during jury selection peterson's camp
says that niece who was dubbed
strawberry shortcake by the media did
not disclose she was being by a
boyfriend while she was pregnant they
say that bias is grounds for a new trial
this week the stanislaus county district
attorney's office announced nice will
receive immunity before testifying at an
upcoming evidentiary hearing on february
25th previously niece had said without
immunity she would invoke her fifth
amendment right the evidentiary hearing
is expected to last about one week after
that a judge will have 90 days to
determine whether peterson deserves a
new trial
let's bring back legal analysts kirk
nermey and tony austin as we dive into
this strawberry shortcake of an issue
terry what's immunity in this setting
how does it protect niece and if she
didn't get it how would it look like
invoking her fifth amendment right well
look immunity means that she doesn't
have to
be prosecuted for anything she might say
and she could say things that could be
used against her here the fact is she
did fail to disclose first of all the
domestic violence but also she had been
involved in some legal proceedings she
can talk about that and she can explain
why she didn't raise it and the
explanation she has sort of intimated in
the past was that she didn't know that
this was a legal proceeding and she
didn't consider herself a victim so she
can explain that and it won't be used
against her without the immunity brian
she could be held accountable for not
revealing that and she could face some
sort of penalty as far as that's
concerned so i think it was smart of her
to ask for this and to
absolutely get it for her testimony yeah
kirk what's a win for peterson look like
in questioning nice in this kind of
hearing
sure i think there's different levels of
winning brian because we first talk
about her being untruthful during the
questionnaire and during vore dyer
because if she makes those admissions
that gives the peterson team fuel to
argue that the trial was tainted but if
it goes further than that if she says
well based on that i wasn't going to
listen to all the evidence i had my mind
made up all the way my experience was
consistent with this something of that
nature that raises the stakes that makes
it harder to deny that the trial was
tainted and in this time of the olympics
if you will the gold medal victory is
for her to say i went in there i didn't
have any any
chance that i was going to acquit this
man and i went into the jury and voiced
my opinion and never ultimately tainted
the whole jury and then that would make
the quest for a new trial for the
peterson team
impossible for a judge to deny under the
sixth amendment yeah so using your
analogy kirk let's see how the peterson
team does whether they stick the landing
or kind of fumble it here we'll see is
that uh hearing expected come up soon
thank you both coming up on law on crime
daily the death of a 22 year old emir
lock what we know so far about the no
knock warrant that led to his death plus
the so-called daytona serial killer i'll
look ahead of the case as jury selection
gets underway
[Music]
here at law and crime we cover cases big
and small from coast to coast
occasionally that means the trial of an
accused serial killer jury selection
began this week in a florida courtroom
for robert hayes whose alleged crimes
span a decade investigators say he's
responsible for the murders of not one
but three women here's jesse weber with
more about this case and how a single
cigarette butt led police to linking
hayes to several cold cases
we have been able to take what we
believe is a serial killer off the
streets and
had we've not done this we're pretty
sure that he would have killed again
robert hayes who's accused of being the
daytona beach serial killer goes before
a jury to begin his trial for the
alleged murder of three women a crime
which could lead to a death sentence
investigators say from
to
2005-2006
robert hayes was a criminal justice
student at bethune-cookman university in
daytona beach florida during that time a
serial killer terrorized the area
police believe hayes is the man
responsible this trial includes charges
in connection to the deaths of three
women laquita gunther julie green and
awana patton who authorities allege were
sex workers in volusia county it started
in 2005 with the murder of 45 year old
laquita gunther
gunther who was left in a kneeling
position in an alleyway partially
clothed on christmas eve 2005 had been
shot in the head and police had no
suspects just three weeks later the
murder of 34 year old mother of four
julie greene who was a friend of
gunther's she was found dead in a ditch
near a construction site and had also
been shot about a month later a tip came
into police with the whereabouts of 35
year old awana patton
she too had been shot and was found on a
dirt road hayes is also linked but not
charged for another murder around the
same time in 2008 at the time police had
discovered a pattern and believed the
killer would strike again
then the cases went cold but then a
murder a decade later the body of
another woman who also worked as a
prostitute was discovered this time the
woman had been strangled detectives knew
rachel bay's death and the other three
shooting deaths were all connected
through dna and ballistics but couldn't
identify the killer robert hayes then
came into the picture and investigators
charged him with rachel bay's murder he
also became suspect number one in the
daytona beach murders officers put hayes
under surveillance three years after
bay's murder while he was at a bus stop
hayes dropped a cigarette butt which
changed the course of the investigation
hayes dna linked him to the killings
we were able to get a dna profile of an
unidentified male
that was entered into codis which is the
national dna database in december of
2016 we will return with a hit from
three cases in daytona beach
that led us to daytona and speaking with
their detectives this case has been
worked nonstop since then
we were able to identify a suspect
through people that they totally had
talked with
he lived up in daytona during their
homicides he lived here during the
homicide of rachel bay we were able to
identify
robert tyrone hayes as our suspect for
this trial hayes faces three counts of
first degree murder and sexual battery
charges if convicted he could face the
death penalty for law and crime daily
i'm jesse weber
the judge in the case has ruled
prosecutors can mention hayes is
suspected of killing rachel bay but
aren't allowed to say how she was killed
the judge also ruled no one in the case
is allowed to refer to hayes as a serial
killer throughout the trial once a jury
is selected law and crime network will
have capital gamble coverage from
florida legal analyst kirk nermey and
co-host terry austin join us to break
down this upcoming trial terry all three
of haye's alleged victims are female sex
workers why do you think that is and how
does a prosecution use this in the case
well obviously he targeted these
individuals because they're vulnerable
it's easy to pick them up they are
already there and ready willing and able
to go with someone and they are often in
these desperate financial situations and
willing to be with someone and they're
trying to make a living however they can
so he's taking advantage of these women
because they are easy targets and you
see he's discarding the bodies as if
they are garbage i think that the
prosecution is going to be able to use
this because hopefully they can show
that there is a tie between the crimes
and that there is a similar motive and
similar preparation for these crimes and
they can use that against him so we'll
see what happens yeah kirk unlikely
we're going to see video surveillance
unlikely to see someone in the stand say
hey he did it it seems that ballistics
and dna link haze to these three women
what do you anticipate the defense will
be in this case
right well you know as as somebody who
practiced capital defense work for a
number of years i know that job number
one of a capital defense attorney is to
save the client's life so in a case like
this you have to look at it in a way
that they're not necessarily trying to
gain the acquittal but save someone's
life so when we talk about all the the
dna all the links to these three crimes
what we're really going to be talking
about in terms of defense is not sowing
reasonable doubt but sewing that just
little tiny bit of doubt in hopes that
that little bit of doubt will make one
juror feel uncomfortable in sentencing
mr hayes to death because that's really
the goal is to obtain a life sentence
here not an acquaintance yeah as the
defense usually says you just need one
just one juror to say they're unsure or
that they're not guilty uh it'll be
interesting to see how this case plays
out and see how the ballistics as well
as the dna points to one person or
doesn't again make sure to follow law
and crime network for capital gabriel
coverage
and another case started a lengthy jury
selection process monday in one of the
largest murder cases in ohio's history
william hughsel is a former doctor
accused of giving lethal amounts of
painkillers to over two dozen patients
between may 2015 and november of 2018.
few sales attorney jose baez known for
representing several high-profile
defendants including casey anthony says
the former doctor was simply providing
comfort care for critically ill patients
hugh sill was initially charged with 25
counts of murder 11 of those were
dismissed last month as prosecutors
decided to focus on the patients who
received the highest amount of fentanyl
prosecutors previously said if convicted
hugh sill can only serve so many life
terms and that it was a waste of
resources and money to incarcerate a man
for more lifetimes than he has
each of the 14 counts carries a
mandatory sentence of 15 years to life
if convicted 900 people were summoned in
december for jury duty opening
statements are expected to start
february 22nd
when we come back a judge approved no
knock warrant leads to the death of a 22
year old african-american man we head to
minnesota for the latest developments in
the death of amir lock
welcome back to law and crime daily one
week after the death of 22 year old
black man amir locke was shot and killed
police arrest locke's cousin the suspect
of the no knock warrant that was issued
body camera footage shows what happened
last wednesday when police entered an
apartment early that morning locke was
sleeping on the couch at his cousin's
apartment an initial press release from
the minneapolis police department stated
locke had a handgun pointed at the
officers the video seems to tell a
different story it shows officers
entering and announcing their presence
after going through the door an officer
then kicks the couch which prompts locke
to wake up after that an officer off
screen shot lock this shooting as well
as others like the one involving braun
and taylor in kentucky has prompted city
council members and minneapolis mayor
jacob fry to discuss no knock warrant
policy within their city
prior to november of 2020
there was no there wasn't a no knock
slash no announced warrant policy in the
city of minneapolis as of november 30th
2020
uh our policy reform then required
officers to announce their presence and
their purpose prior to entry when
serving any type of warrant including a
no not barring circumstances that could
potentially be dangerous where there was
imminent threat to the public uh or an
individual now the moratorium which was
put in place i believe on friday
uh that then additionally prevents the
requesting
of a no knock no announce warrant like
back in 2020 why didn't you just like
do a full-on band
certainly uh we could have said that in
all circumstances you're required to
both knock
and announce
uh these are instances where
you know
we could always go further
uh and i think in this instance
with this policy we need to
lock's cousin 17 makai speed was the
subject of the original warrant speed
was arrested monday and charged with
second-degree murder and a january 10th
homicide
kirk do you think we will see criminal
charges in this case for the officers
you know brian while these actions
demonstrate the ills of no knock
warrants and what could happen we see in
this 15 second or so video
you know the police coming in storming
in and we see the gun being pulled
and unfortunately in that
pre-bearded time and i understand there
might be more body cam footage coming
forward that we don't really see
anything where criminal criminal charges
can be
uh proffered i don't see any
recklessness any disregard some of the
things that we've heard about coming out
of minnesota the only criminal
charges i could see is if there's
something else in the body cam or if
there was something a flaw in the
warrant if the
evidence in the warrant or supported to
get the no knock warrant was somehow
invalid and based on police figure other
than that i don't see criminal charges
coming out of that's this case yeah this
may just stay on the civil side terry
mayor fry has put a moratorium on no
knock warrants unless there's an
imminent danger to the public what do
you think the future of no knock
warrants in minneapolis is
well there have had been so many
problems in minneapolis about no knock
warrants and other places in the country
as well and their use should be
extremely limited if at all i think a
moratorium completely may be the way to
go when you see these sort of no-knock
warrants it's really dangerous for both
sides of the door it's dangerous for the
police because they're coming in and
they could be surprised if someone sees
them coming in with the gun and then
immediately that individual is on the
defensive and it's dangerous for the
individual obviously because they could
get shot so i mean i think there are
very limited instances if we know that
there's a hostage perhaps but if their
concern is the individual getting away
because it's a criminal they can
surround the place so i think they
should be extremely limited or banned
yeah the risks seem to outweigh the
benefits and we'll see how that
continues thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you